oh my soul bro Winfrey is on the red  carpet right now Oprah Winfrey hit the  red carpet Monday night for the premiere  of owns a new drama series at Queen a  sugar Hey Oh was looking a fit and  fabulous and an LBD paired with a super  high pony you're looking svelte by the  way I just have to tell you thank you  observing you with them take your  picture hard to do on a movie set you  know it's so hard you know you're  working those long days and then by the  end of the day my god there's a bag of  hot cheetos calling your name but i  gotta feeling' to leave the craft table  and ask for a plum we have a plum please  anyway you got some good just am I going  all good discipline yeah my friend you  looking good over there looking good